a una situación bastante compleja porque
no nos evidencia que vamos a tener a un
parlamento que además viene como
institución de experiencias saboteadoras
a otros presidentes a otros antecesores
de hecho el parlamento ha colocado por
lo menos a dos presidentes en el último
quinquenio haciendo una un
enfrentamiento entre el legislativo y el
ejecutivo de manera constante una
negociación que muchas veces no ha
tenido los mejores fines y que se han
nombrado en muchas negociaciones bajo la
mesa con la finalidad no solamente de
colocar a un presidente de la república
sino sabotear de manera sistemática va a
ser muy compleja esta situación sin
embargo en base a la negociación y al
diálogo se podría evitar que tengan una
mayoría más absoluta de las fuerzas de
oposición pero de lo que sí sabemos que
puede hacer mano el presidente castillo
es con la movilización ciudadana
en la víspera de las elecciones
siguiente muchas situaciones en que se
ponían en tela de juicio de esta
contabilidad de votos ellos no han
tenido problemas en movilizar a la
población en general y creo que va a
utilizar mucho de esto y si es necesario
va a recurrir a referentes o consultas
populares con la finalidad de darle
viabilidad en caso como siempre y como
hay previsión aunque el parlamento
juegue este rol obstruccionista